[Music]
on this sunday night
heartache in the kausis first nation
the poignant vigil for the hundreds of
victims of a residential school
the world is going to hear about our
historical trauma
mounting anxiety in florida as families
wait for answers
if she's underneath that rubble alive
it'll be a miracle
plus the canadians unaccounted for our
jackson proskow is at the scene tonight
bc's sweltering heat dome and the damage
to crops
plus confidence in canada's team to
score the stanley cup we've made it this
far right so
why not we can do it but one montreal
canadien will be
mia
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the grief for
victims of a residential school in
saskatchewan
the kawasa's first nation held a vigil
to honor hundreds of indigenous children
believed to be buried in unmarked graves
the mourning is accompanied by anger
directed at the catholic church
responsible for operating the school as
heather york's west explains
there is more work to be done to uncover
the truth as indigenous communities
try to heal
they came together in mourning and
prayer
[Applause]
the people of the kawasa's first nation
hosting a gravesite vigil saturday
open to anyone who wanted to come and
honor those found
in as many as 751 unmarked graves near
the former site of the maryvale
residential school
we had a lot of support from all the
communities around the area here because
they all have loved ones here
the unmarked graves now identified by
not only a flag but a small
solar light not everyone found buried
here went to the residential school
but some did finding these children at
last has
come as a relief to some definitely
grief that goes along with
what's what's been found out but there's
also a sense of relief because
we've been talking about this our
community our people our elders have
been talking about this for many years
it's
been hidden for so long at 7 51
mourners marked a moment of silence
before residential school survivors
shared stories
of a past filled with pain it was
so important it was important for me to
be with with my community
with my leadership and
take part in in the process of honoring
you know the children that went through
residential school
it has been an emotionally difficult few
days for many families here
but the work is not done yet the next
steps is to continue on with the the
survey
to to make sure that we don't have any
that we missed
and to put markings on on the unmarked
graves and have a
have a name to them to do that cowas
first nation is hoping to obtain
historical documents from the catholic
church across the country catholic and
other christian churches are facing
mounting community anger
over their role in the operation of
residential schools
in bc a fifth church the saint paul's
anglican church on the gitweng first
nation was set ablaze
this time the flames were extinguished
before the building was lost
while i understand that hostility and
needing to find a way to heal from it
that church was built by our ancestors
in the late 1800s
by the hands of our elders
at the time with such a great sense of
pride in edmonton police are
investigating after a statue of pope
john paul ii
was vandalized with red paint but after
the discovery of 215
unmarked graves in kamloops b.c and as
many as 751 in saskatchewan
emotions are running high sunday marks
the fourth
day since the discovery here was
announced the day began with a
traditional
pipe ceremony at the site a community
feast is also planned
it's a ceremonial practice believed to
help the spirits
continue on to the spiritual world robin
heather york's west near the cows first
nation in saskatchewan
there is some support for those who need
it the indian residential school
survivors crisis line is confidential
and available
24 hours a day the toll-free number is
1-866-925-4419
to florida now where the death toll has
risen to nine in that catastrophic condo
collapse
part of the 12-story tower came crashing
down early thursday morning
while people were sleeping more than 150
people remain
unaccounted for including four canadians
according to global affairs canada
our jackson proskow is at the scene for
us tonight jackson what do we know about
these canadians
robin the four canadians were spread
between two units they're listed as
unaccounted for right now because they
were in the collapsed section of the
building
and they belong to three different
families we do know that relatives of at
least one of those families are on route
here to miami
and when they get here they will likely
arrive at the hotel behind me that's the
family reunification center
where all day long we've seen families
arrive they cry in the streets they hug
each other they try to console each
other
but it is an incredible painful
experience for them being here it is
incredibly difficult for them to be here
as they come to grips with what their
family members and loved ones have been
through
earlier today we actually saw several
miami miami beach city buses pull up
here
and they took the family members to the
collapse site giving them a chance to
see
that hollowed ground right now where of
course there are so many
unanswered questions about the fate of
their loved ones i also had a chance to
speak with canada's consul general here
in the miami area
and she tells me there are incredible
challenges in providing support to these
grieving families
we're also in a situation here
specifically where
we're putting pieces of a puzzle
together
what we're trying to find out was who
was in that building but
we don't have that information no one
does so local authorities
have the information that they can piece
together we have information that we can
piece together
and as they go back and forth of course
their priority is making sure that the
families get as much information as
possible
and robin that includes making sure they
know how much support awaits them here
in miami beach
but jackson how are all the families
receiving information and updates
inside that hotel room they're being
given regular briefings essentially by
officials here and search and rescue
officials
to bring them up to date one of the key
things here of course is proceeding with
caution and
sensitivity and they want to make sure
that families are given any news
especially any grim news
before the general public is made aware
to help them cope and help them
understand
and robin there is an incredible support
network for those families here on the
ground everything from support
dogs to international relief groups with
specialty in handling this kind of
trauma
jackson prescott in surfside florida
thanks jackson
crews are working around the clock with
the painstaking task of trying to
recover bodies but they have to go
slowly jennifer johnson explains why
search and rescue teams have cut a 12
meter deep trench into the rubble of the
surf side condominium building
revealing more grim news for families
waiting to hear the fate of their loved
ones
we've continued all night to build that
that trench
and as a result of that we were able to
recover
four additional bodies in the rubble
as well as additional human remains
family members are being asked to
provide dna samples so remains can be
identified quickly
many are still holding out hope
including mike noriega
whose father found his missing
grandmother's birthday card amid the
destruction
if she's underneath that rubble alive
it'll be a miracle of the ages
and if she's not i know that her soul is
in heaven
search and rescuers have to move slowly
fires deep
into the debris and shifting rubble are
making their efforts even more difficult
the building moved this is this is why
we have this technology
that gave us enough time to evacuate the
site until the building
settled officials are now working on
relocating residents of a sister
condominium complex
who have concerns about their own
building collapsing we have
huge amounts of money that have been
pledged or that have been donated
there's going to be folks that are that
are displaced there's folks that's lives
have been shattered as a result of this
a 2018 engineers report found cracking
and structural damage in the building's
parking garage
in walls columns and beams work on that
was scheduled but hadn't started
attorneys for the condominium
association are questioning why the
problems were ignored for so long
if there is an engineer who believes
that
concrete pitting and falling and rebar
deterioration poses a hazardous
risk to the building and a risk of
collapse that
needs to be clear that report also
called for distressed concrete slabs
under the pool deck to be removed and
replaced but that hadn't happened either
chunks of the rubble are being moved to
large warehouses to help investigators
piece together
what caused the structure to come
crashing down in a matter of seconds
jennifer johnson global news washington
people in bc are scrambling to find
relief from what environment canada is
calling a dangerous heat
wave an unusually strong bridge of high
pressure bubbled up over the province on
friday
creating a heat dome and that dome is
trapping air that is hot
and oppressive this is unusual weather
for this part of canada and it's being
made worse by the fact that 60 percent
of bc residents
don't have air conditioning at home
right now health officials say the risk
of extreme heat exposure
is higher than cova 19. the heat wave is
taking a toll on bc's economy
abbotsford an hour outside vancouver is
in the fraser valley
and it's considered the bread basket of
farming in the province
as global zamatagahi is here to tell us
farmers are worried their crops and
livelihoods are being destroyed
ahmad well robin it didn't take long for
this
crushing heat wave to begin impacting
bc's agriculture especially here
in the fraser valley this abbotsford
raspberry farm
a minute by minute hundreds of thousands
of dollars could be just
evaporating into the sky and rows of
crop as far as
you can see may now be essentially
useless
look at easy leaves yeah these are
already burned you know these leaves
these men some raspberry farmers for 40
years have never
seen so much damage in such a short time
and this is
a natural disaster affecting after the
the covid pandemic so we would like to
urge to the
minister of agriculture to step in as
well as to the
federal government officials to step in
a call for government help because the
excruciating sun and heat over the last
48 hours is cooking and rotting fresh
raspberries what we're seeing with this
heat wave
is the raspberry crop is literally being
baked
it's being baked and cooked on the vine
and it will have little value if any by
it
by the time this heat wave is done the
sunburned fruits cannot be sold meaning
hundreds if not thousands of acres of
crops are being
wasted as temperatures in the area break
right
it should be changing from green to red
but it is changing from
green to white as you can see and what's
more is that parts of metro vancouver
and the fraser valley are also under an
air quality advisory due to high
concentrations of ground
level ozone which makes working on these
farms even more difficult robin
matagahi in abbotsford bc thank you
ahmad
okay let's bring in global news
meteorologist yvonne shell yvonne first
of all
what is this heat dome the heat tone
that's blanketing across both
the western side of the country now it's
a significant ridge of high pressure
that builds in place
and it traps the heat underneath and
what it allows is mother nature to crank
up the heat
and keep significant heat
record-breaking heat for several days
now
it is blanketing both alberta and bee
and we're going to continue to watch
this as this ridge continues to build
with the heat warning we've got
temperatures highs into the 40s with the
humidex feeling into the mid 40s
and overnight lows and that'll stretch
in towards alberta we'll be dipping down
just to 20 degrees
it has been blistering in parts of bc
very unusual for this part of canada in
june
surely records are breaking absolutely
and this is significant and
unprecedented because we typically see
this
in july and august and now we're
breaking records in the month of june
but we also have the potential to break
all-time record highs for example
lillian linton this is in bc will be
exceeding 44 degrees last record was
back in 1941
and all-time records for alberta
edmonton will be keeping a close eye on
these numbers
over exceeding 37 degrees an old record
that was set back in 1937. robin
all right yvonne thanks so much for that
infrastructure minister catherine
mckenna won't be running in the next
election to focus on tackling
climate change one of her first jobs in
the liberal government in 2015 was
environment minister
she had to stick handle the introduction
of a price on carbon emissions
mckenna has represented the writing of
ottawa center for six years
it could be a writing for former bank of
canada governor mark carney
should he decide to run coming up how
did classified military papers about a
british warship
end up at a bus stop plus the scrutiny
of australia's low vaccination rates
with a fast-moving variant
[Applause]
it might look like game day in toronto
but it's vaccine day
the scotiabank arena home of the maple
leafs and the raptors
opened its doors at 7am the goal of the
mass vaccination campaign is to
administer shots to 25
000 people and if successful that would
double the national record for the most
people vaccinated in a single day at a
single clinic
in australia outbreaks linked to the
delta variant have forced millions of
people into lockdown
the country's biggest city sydney is
bracing for surging cases which
could force the government to extend
stay-at-home orders the delta variant is
highly contagious and has dealt a major
blow to australia's
zero cobit strategy and as redmond
shannon reports
the concern now is the low vaccination
rates down under
sydney's famous bondi beach is the
epicenter of its
relatively large covet 19 outbreak
30 new cases of the delta variant in the
state of new south wales
sunday more than 5 million people are
under
a stay-at-home order exercise is one of
the few reasons residents are allowed
outside
i also do want to foreshadow that given
how contagious this strain of the virus
is we do anticipate that in the next few
days
case numbers are likely to increase even
beyond what we've seen today
that is because household contacts of
the cases are expected to test positive
too
the measure of our success will be to
limit the number of people who've been
out and about in the community
who get the disease in a country that's
pursuing a zero covet strategy
this outbreak is the most serious this
year
another lockdown for 48 hours is in
place
three thousand kilometers away in darwin
this is a challenging time for the
territory and for all territorians
as i said it's our biggest threat yet
it's our biggest test
the concerns about the delta variant are
particularly acute because
less than five percent of the country is
fully vaccinated
new zealand has suspended its
three-month-old
travel bubble with its nearest neighbor
authorities are particularly worried
about an
infected australian visitor who
certainly did a lot of sightseeing
as of yesterday 2444 potential contacts
have been identified
as a result of our investigations here
in wellington none of those contacts
have tested positive so
far but the case highlights how
difficult it can be
to pursue a zero covert strategy redmond
shannon global news
london britain's defense ministry is in
hot water after classified documents
were found
at a bus stop according to bbc news a
member of the public
found 50 pages of sensitive military
papers
some relate to an incident off crimea
last week when russian forces reacted
aggressively to a british warship
sailing through
the files suggest its passage was
calculated to
incite a response the papers also
contained potential future plans for a
military presence in afghanistan
on twitter the ministry says the files
were reported missing last week
and an investigation is underway
still ahead the tragedy of a canadian
soldier and his family
did the system failed a veteran who was
struggling with mental health
you're watching global national
four years after a soldier from nova
scotia killed his family and himself
an inquiry has revealed critical gaps in
the system meant to help veterans with
post-traumatic stress disorder
lionel desmond struggled with his mental
health after serving in afghanistan
as ross lord explains the inquiry heard
there was a lack of coordination
and resources to help those who have
served our country
lionel desmond was known as a cheerful
family man
he descended into paranoia after coming
home from a tour in afghanistan in 2007
devastated by ptsd desmond shot and
killed his wife shayna
their ten-year-old daughter and his
mother before killing himself
his case manager told the fatality
inquiry investigating the tragedy
she did her best it was not out of
neglect you know what i mean like it's
not
but the inquiry heard it took veterans
affairs canada six months to appoint a
case manager
even though desmond's disorder was
already obvious a delay marie paul do
set blames
on a lack of resources and budget cuts
imposed by the former conservative
government
some days he called the office and he
was in
in distress and then there was not much
that could be done in the moment other
than spend time with him
other veterans with ptsd say it's bad
enough they're bounced from the military
medical system to the private system
where doctors can be hard to find they
say losing precious months without a
case
manager is inexcusable when you're
dealing with ptsd
six months you might as well say 600
years
okay it it it's a time frame that
doesn't register and doesn't help
things can go so horrible in six months
a lack of sharing medical records
between the military and provinces is
another problem
but this veteran who wrote a book about
the military bureaucracy
says there are signs of improvement
within veterans affairs
they started hiring far more case
managers
and they still need more desmond's
sister-in-law testified he complained
about being a victim of anti-black
racism before he left the canadian
forces
the inquiry is examining desmond's
access to mental health and domestic
violence services
the training of the professionals he
encountered and whether he should have
been able to buy a rifle
the hearings are scheduled to end this
fall ross lord
global news up next habs fans are
excited about their team getting to the
stanley cup final
but a key player is staying behind
tomorrow night the montreal canadiens
will play their first stanley cup final
in nearly 30 years
if that's not exciting enough it's also
the first time a canadian hockey team
is this close to winning it since 2011.
one player is being forced to sit out
because of kofi 19
but as michael couture explains habs
fans aren't worried
the montreal canadiens were remarkably
relaxed for a team that is about to play
in the stanley cup finals bringing home
hockey's holy grail just got a bit
tougher protocol
habb's general manager mark bel javen
told reporters joelle armia
was placed in covid 19 protocol by the
league
which doesn't mean he has the virus but
it does mean
he won't be with the team for game one
in tampa bay
army's obviously an important and
important player for us it's
it's just another another little piece
of adversity we'll have to deal with
adversity that has included pausing the
season for a week when armia and another
player were in the same covid19 protocol
losing key players to injuries late in
the season
and then losing their coach for the last
round of the playoffs
when he had coveted 19. that's despite
the entire team
and staff receiving their second doses
of vaccine
on june 9th and as you'd expect habs
fans
aren't worried we're the last team to
make the playoffs first team to make the
finals right
got to do it that unwavering faith isn't
a shock
in a town where hockey is considered a
religion
the franchise goalie is seen as a savior
especially carrie price he wants that
cup he's focused he wants that cup and
if you think the pressure of trying to
be the first canadian team to win the
stanley cup since
1993 is weighing on the players
look no further than the habs goalie
himself whose words
don't always match his tone just
excitement
it's been something that we've been
working
working towards our whole lives the team
embracing the opportunity
as the entire country embraces this team
mike licouter global news ottawa
go habs go and that is global national
for this sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the lighthouse in
port dover ontario
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you